you mentioned at the end of the world
there's a lot of people now worried
about our political climate is that oh
really why yeah that'd be well give us
your take on this maybe you're gonna
have an optimistic note maybe well I
don't know if it's optimistic but I
don't like I don't know I never know
what's gonna happen I'm waiting for
Trump to just staff the White House with
actual Russians yeah well what would
happen if he just came out that this is
Boris Ivan
Spanish suave terrific guy clapping and
laughing but if it happens right most of
America be like what's going on he can't
just tie your Russians and then about
three days will go by and people I guess
that's happening I guess yeah I guess
it's just gonna be Russians there yeah
because apparently Conan there are no
rules to being president we just made
assumptions that they somehow stay in
the same Lane a bit maybe you know at
least well they all behaved more or less
saying well that's not happening and I
just hope someone's writing some rules
down yep just in case we make it through
this one a few do's and dont's might be
nice
I'll make sure I mentioned wait yes are
we done you just call me dude I did it
well both in our 70s yeah I've done this
show I can i play with the band you've
been looking over you know we've been
we've been on the air and I think it in
like two weeks or something we've been
on the air 25 years and this guy has
been coming on constantly for of this
that for 24 of them we you know the
first year we weren't sure about you but
then realized I could alienate people
over and over again yes exactly and then
win them back every time they sing so of
course you can play with the band hold
on let me give you the plug you go get
set up the second season of glow is
available on Netflix
WTF with Marc Maron's available wherever
you download podcasts will be appearing
at the Beacon Theater it's part of the
New York Comedy Festival on Saturday
November 10th
we'll take a little break Bert Kreischer
we come back Mark had some fun
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
you